một bạn nữa
Mình sẽ tranh thủ tâm sự một tí trong
lúc trước khi bắt đầu nhé À đúng rồi hôm
nay
hôm nay chắc là dồn cả hôm trước sẽ có
nhiều nhóm sẽ cần chữa Có gì cứ bình
luận nhé
bình luận nhé
hôm trước Thực ra thì à hôm Thứ năm thì
mình có bấc ở trên công ty mình có đăng
bài thông báo rồi đấy ạ thì
nhưng mà tôi thì tôi và một người sống
ra Tính ra vẫn hơi bị ảnh hưởng bởi cảm
xúc khá nhiều nếu thế và bao gồm trong
cả việc là cảm xúc tôi cái tâm trạng của
tôi nó sẽ ảnh hưởng cả công việc
chắc tôi Tôi nghĩ là kiểu khi mình lớn
lên ấy thì mình sẽ kiểu cân bằng được
điều đấy hơn sẽ không để ảnh ảnh hưởng
bởi cảm xúc nhiều nhưng mà nhưng mà về
cơ bản thì tôi thường hay bị ảnh hưởng
bởi cảm xúc thế nên là sẽ thậm chí có
nhiều hôm mà sẽ có thể dạy khá là hay và
cũng có nhiều hôm thì sẽ kiểu dạng kiểu
không hẳn là tâm trạng tệ nhất Nói chung
là kiểu tâm trạng có thể ví dụ đấy ngày
hôm đấy Kiểu đám mệt mỏi gì đó thì sẽ
dạy kiểu nó sẽ bị nhàm chán hay gì đó
Kiểu cái cái cái cái tông giọng ấy nó sẽ
không kiểu dạng là hào hứng nó sẽ hiểu
kiểu cứ đều đều thì chính khiến cho đính
chính cả sinh viên cũng sẽ nghe kiểu
buồn ngủ hay vân vân tôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi
bị ảnh hưởng bởi cái đấy
Thực ra lớn rồi mình nên mình mình nên
có ngoài việc là mình sẽ phải đối mặt
được với cái việc kiểu thỉnh thoảng có
sống mà thỉnh thoảng mình có rất nhiều
vấn đề nhưng mình sẽ phải đối mặt được
với nó bằng là phải gạt nó sang một bên
để vẫn tiếp tục được công việc
để không làm ảnh hưởng đến ai người khác
nữa đấy thì theo xong rồi nó sẽ Khá
trách nhiệm
cái bậc hôm trước của tôi gà nó cũng
đương nhiên là lỗi của chắc chắn đầu
tiên vẫn là lỗi của mình mình phải thừa
nhận điều đấy ra là kiểu đó là kiểu
nói như nào
tính tôi thực ra là kiểu Tuy là code và
thường hay xem lại code review code của
chính mình
nhưng mà test về cái test thì tôi lại
vẫn chưa test cẩn thận nó lắm thì tôi sẽ
tôi sẽ chở học cụ thể hơn về mấy cái
kiểu test unis để mà để mà kiểu nó sẽ tự
động test tự động test tất cả trường hợp
rồi Có gì tôi sẽ cho mấy ông xem mấy ông
tham khảo nữa
xem thực sự là kiểu để tự máy chạy tự
động test là như nào bởi vì tôi thực ra
hơi lười phụ học thêm về cái mấy cái tế
tổng đấy
tạm thời Thế
hôm nay thì ở trước khi mà chữa cụ thể
cho một nhóm nào đó nhóm mà cần chữa thì
cứ bình luận nhé Thì mình sẽ xin phép
chữa cho à
nó có vài cái nó khá là dị để mà
để mà test kiểu như thế anh làm ở ở cái
trang thương mại điện tử thì anh làm
tính năng tự động đẩy đơn sang cho các
bên đối tác sắp layer thì
một cái trường hợp đấy
tôi sẽ bây giờ tôi sẽ thử tạo ra ta bây
giờ chữa lần lượt cho mấy ông xem mấy
ông hiểu nha cái Menu 2 Cấp này tức là
sao nghĩa là
giả sử là bây giờ tôi có
Mình có database
làm cái Menu 2 cấp đấy Tôi đang làm thậm
chí menu nhiều cấp cũng được nó sẽ kiểu
như sau
database tên là test đi cho tôi sẽ viết
Microsoft đúng không ạ
Hay mình sẽ có cốt luôn
về cái đấy nhé để xem nhé Tôi không có
thư mục test ở đây
mà
thôi không nên À đúng rồi hay tôi Vứt
hết mọi thứ trong học viện này đi sẽ
code ở bên cái học viện này
nhé
sân trong này
nhé nhưng mà tôi sẽ chỉ làm cho 2 cấp
thôi Còn mấy ông muốn làm phức tạp hơn
thì
đấy là việc mấy ông mấy ông sẽ cầm mò
cái đấy sau còn tôi hướng dẫn yêu cầu
đơn giản đã cho dễ hiểu đã còn về để Q
Thực ra công ty sẽ áp dụng cho nhiều
cách khác nhau
để Quỳ tất cả sao nghĩa là vòng lặp nó
cứ gọi gọi gọi gọi đến khi nào hết không
phải vô tận mà chỉ đơn giản là thỉnh
thoảng nó sẽ vô tận Nhưng thỉnh thoảng
nó sẽ gọi cái hết thì thôi
không nó không làm thủ công kiểu hot
code đâu
là amax này mua đồ này đúng không ạ Ở
đây sẽ Giả sử cái vừa rồi nó thể loại đi
mình sẽ cattery
đúng không Mình mình sẽ cột là cột này
nêm rất chuẩn và tiếp theo là
sluck
ra khá hay ở nhưng mà tôi cứ tạm bỏ qua
đã Tôi muốn làm đơn giản trước mình sẽ
có cái con chết này
không nhớ được cái
đương nhiên mình sẽ để luôn label
để tôi thử vẽ kiểu shit cho mấy ông dễ
hình dung nhá Sửa là mình sẽ có ID này
đúng chứ và có mình sẽ gọi là Thoa rừng
ID như này Tôi đặt này đi cho dễ hình
dung hơn nhé
là sao Nó là kiểu Giả sử là một này mình
sẽ là laptop chẳng hạn
muốn là kiểu dạng
Asus chẳng hạn
đi là một ngày thì mình sẽ hiểu à Nghĩa
là là thằng này là thằng con của cái
thằng này đúng không ạ tương tự thế sẽ
có đều như này vẫn là thằng con thằng
này nhưng Giả sử Giả sử tự nhiên mình sẽ
có 4 là điện thoại chẳng hạn
con thằng nào cả nó sẽ độc lập nó sẽ in
ra menu của Độc Lập đúng không ạ Nó sẽ
kiểu laptop này in ra điện thoại này
đúng không sau khi trỏ vào cái laptop
thì sẽ hiển thị Asus và đều chẳng hạn
thế tương tự Thế mình sẽ có ví dụ ở đây
Apple chẳng hạn Giả sử thế đâu nhé tôi
vẫn Giả sử nhá Nó sẽ là 4 nhà chẳng hạn
cho vào laptop thì Asus và đều đúng chứ
còn chả trỏ và điện thoại sẽ hiển thị ra
Apple đúng không Tôi vẫn đang chỉ làm
theo kiểu menu 2 cấp thôi chứ không phải
menu theo cậu là
là trò với thằng Apple nó hiển thị ra
thêm cái nữa Gì gì đó nữa thì cái đấy
tôi chưa Hướng dẫn vội đúng không ạ sẽ
không hướng dẫn đâu cái đấy mấy ông muốn
hiểu về đệ quy mấy ông lại mò thêm
những đại khái Thì bây giờ mình sẽ tạo
cái bảng này trước đúng không ạ Mình sẽ
tạo bảng này
[âm nhạc]
Bây giờ sửa là tôi tôi không làm tính
năng
bắt chước giống như bên Excel đi như này
tiếp theo là Asus này
sẽ có một laptop chuẩn luôn này giao nữa
là đều
mình sẽ có
laptop đúng không tiếp theo là điện
thoại này
không có gì cả tiếp theo là Apple này sẽ
có là điện thoại OK này đấy bây giờ bây
giờ cái thứ mà đầu tiên là để mà Tôi
hiển thị cái Menu đúng chứ
nó sẽ là như thế này
tôi sẽ
vào bên controller
này mình ghi hết vào trong này đúng
không Ok
mình sẽ có một cái test đi này
đặt tên Đây là test menu đi
menu.plus.vn
cattery về đúng chứ
nếu mà Trưởng Giả lấy tất cả như này rồi
toàn bộ tất cả thì nó lại dễ quá đúng
không dễ quá thử mấy ông nha
rồi Ford
qua thẻ a các thứ thì hiển thị ra như
này thôi Sợ đóng Air forex như này đúng
chứ đúng không Nếu mà làm theo kiểu như
này và tôi sẽ
chạy bên này
sẽ có là ghét này test menu này
nó sẽ nhảy đến test menu
gì cả
như này rồi mình sẽ có học viện trong
test này gạch chéo test máy nu
nó sẽ in ra như thế này đúng không ạ
echo nhé
để làm cũng được không sao cả
nhưng mà đôi khi con em không nên xử lý
mà vẫn xử lý là mình sẽ phải lồng Tự
lồng hết mọi thứ ở trong bác em xong rồi
Chỉ cần lên Hiển thị như anh đã từng nói
là xử lý iPhone
trừ những cái tính toán này hiện tại con
số bác em nó sẽ trả về dữ liệu thô rồi
còn em hiển thị con số nó khác
để tính để tự động tính nó khác Còn đây
là về cơ bản thì mình phải xác định rõ
Thảo thằng con là thằng Trang ngay từ
bác em rồi để mà xử lý đổ đổ về cho
người dùng đổ về nó là api nghĩa là
không phải là ở mỗi fan lens của em mà
về sau giả sử bên thứ ba muốn gọi đến
cho em để mà lấy Thông tin Dữ liệu về
chẳng hạn thì em cần phải trả về cho nó
những cái dữ liệu đã được xử lý một cách
tương đối để nó nhìn vào nó hình dung nó
hiểu hiểu không Nói chung là api có
nhiều tác dụng lắm
Nói chung đại Khái ở đây Nếu mấy ông
nhìn thấy kiểu menu kiểu thô như này thì
vứt đúng không ạ Rõ ràng là tôi đang
muốn là ít nhất là thằng Laptop này sẽ
có thằng con là Asus và Dell xong rồi
thằng điện thoại sẽ Apple đúng không Thì
bây giờ cái đầu tiên mình cần làm Đó là
mình sẽ chỉ lấy chỉ lấy thằng trà để
hiển thị ra thằng cha Thôi thì mình sẽ ở
đây mình sẽ là bởi vì như này
xong rồi mình sẽ
này đi này
chị Hiền
lấy thằng con như thế nào thì bây giờ
cái thằng lauriel có cái rất là hay đó
là nó nó sẽ có khái niệm là
sẽ lấy thằng con Và thậm chí là tôi nhớ
không lầm là nó có lấy được cả thằng con
thằng con con con con con con mãi nữa cơ
nó là khái niệm mà gì nhỉ
hồi trước tôi nhớ có một cái là kiểu nó
định quy hộ mình cái vụ đấy
Còn nếu không Mình làm đơn giản thôi nó
sẽ chỉ hát Xoan thôi
odhistourder như này hay phết nhỉ
nhớ Có Hồi trước nó có nhắc cái vụ để
quên một lần
Custom này
[âm nhạc]
rồi
sẽ là
nhiều đúng không các từ
đi
là hiểu này mình sẽ gọi đến chính nó
này được
sao và
tôi thử chạy thử cho mấy ông xem tại
trang không có gì cả
à đây tôi thử Return Chính thằng cattery
này mấy ông sẽ xem nhé
Đây mình thấy là thằng laptop nó đã có
Asus và Dell Apple
đúng chứ Thế giờ chỉ việc hiển thị ra
thôi rất là dễ mấy ông thấy ở đây bên
nào nếu mà dùng rasionship thì sẽ sẽ
thấy là thằng này có hai thằng con ở đây
rồi và thằng này có một thằng con thôi
nó tự động nối hộ cho mình nên là việc
in ra bên này sẽ rất là dễ bên này ông
sẽ chỉ kiểm tra là
à đâu
xỉ thật nhìn Ông Sỹ thật
thì mình sẽ
đấy cho khác đi
xong rồi mình sẽ Ford
vẫn xịn thật đúng không in ra từng thằng
như này
và Kết quả nó sẽ như này Ok chứ
kiểu 2 cấp còn như mà Vừa rồi tôi bảo là
đây chỉ cần thêm cái đoạn này sẽ lấy
menu kiểu dạng như cấp này cậu đa cấp là
nó sẽ kiểu gọi gọi gọi liên tục để nó
các thứ nó lằng nhằng hơn thì cái này em
mấy ông tự mò thêm sau tôi lại cho mấy
ông từ khóa này mấy ông mò rồi đúng
không ạ
như thế nhưng câu truy vấn của nó không
phải là để quy nó là cái rất là hay Tôi
thấy đó là không hề gọi điện Q kiểu này
đúng không Nhưng câu truy vấn của nó
không phải để quy thôi nhé Nó sẽ Tôi nhớ
Chính xác là hình như nó tạo thành hai
hay ba câu truy vấn thôi
nghĩa là không phải là ý tôi tức là sao
ví dụ Giả sử là ông ông lấy ví dụ lúc
đầu mấy ông thầy nha là có câu truy vấn
để lấy toàn bộ thằng cha đây Đúng chứ
Đúng chứ Sau đó thì with thằng con nữa
nhưng mà đây 2 cấp nghĩa là có hai câu
truy vấn một câu thì lấy toàn bộ thằng
cha và một câu Lấy toàn bộ thằng con của
thằng cha này đúng chứ nhưng mà Nếu giả
sử mà là đệ quy theo kiểu như cấp thì rõ
ràng là vừa rồi có tôi đang làm 2 cấp
thì hai câu truy vấn thế nên là giả sử
menu 4 cấp hay là 5 cấp hay thậm chí về
sau n cấp thì sẽ ở bấy nhiêu câu chỉ vấn
không không phải như thế thằng cái đệq
này tôi nhớ ông là nó chỉ hình như là
tạo thành ba câu chưa vấn thôi Thì vẫn
chỉ hai Tôi không chắc lắm nhưng mấy ông
sẽ thử xem lại là hiểu ha Xem
nhé
thêm cả tính năng khác nữa
cái bài toán tiếp theo toán đó là lấy ra
danh sách trống tất cả các bạn đều đang
làm bài toán đồ ăn hay là để làm đề tài
nghiệp vụ nó sẽ có đến giờ thời gian có
nhiều bạn vẫn đang thắc mắc tôi thế nào
là nghiệp vụ thì nó thì với tôi
thường nghiệp vụ thì nó sẽ có rất nhiều
thứ Nó là kiểu dạng là là cái từ nghiệp
vụ ấy theo như tôi hiểu nhé không phải
nhà từ điển học cho lắm và tôi dốt văn
nữa nhưng mà theo như tôi hiểu thì cái
nghiệp vụ ở đây nó là hắn chỉ là là
những cái liên quan đến cái nghiệp vụ
khó ấy chứ không phải đương nhiên là làm
công việc gì thì có nghiệp vụ riêng
người ta người ta có quy trình làm việc
người ta nhưng ý tôi nghiệp vụ cái đồ ăn
2 cần làm những cái nhiệm vụ khó Tức là
sao và thứ nhất là bài toán về quản lý
con người thứ hai là quản lý tiền bạc
thứ ba là là quản lý lịch hiểu không
Nghĩa là tại sao lại phải có những cái
cái một cái gọi là khó bởi vì cái đầu
vào của mấy ông nhập vào và cái đầu vặn
đầu ra ấy nó có sự chênh lệch nó sự khác
biệt hiểu không Tại sao đồ án 1 không
thực tính ở bài toán nghiệp vụ bởi vì đồ
án 1 về cơ bản nó chỉ ở trang web Một là
tin tức là tất cả mình đang cái gì nó
hiển thị đúng cái thứ mình vừa đăng thì
nó không phải nghiệp vụ hiểu chứ nó
không có gì khó ở đấy cả mình nhập vào
như là mình nghĩ là đúng thế đúng không
ạ tiếp theo đó là trang web bán hàng
chẳng hạn bạn trang web bán hàng thực ra
là cái nghiệp vụ của nó không hẳn là khó
lắm Tức là sao về cơ bản thì khách hàng
đặt hàng sau đó đã hiển thị cái đơn mà
khách hàng đã đặt nó chẳng có gì khó cả
admin vào xem đơn Khách hàng đã đã đạt
cùng lắm là thêm một tí thống kê thôi
nên là nó không tính là nghiệp vụ chuyên
sâu lắm cái mức độ khó để mà giải quyết
cái đấy Không hẳn là cao thế cái bài
toán nghiệp vụ của cái đồ án 2 những cái
nào là khó thì như tôi vừa nói thứ nhất
là bài toán quản lý con người tức là sao
nghĩa là con còn mình sẽ nhập vào giờ
giấc các thứ để về sau xuất ra được cái
lịch làm việc của từng người thậm chí là
về sau nó sẽ tự động đề xuất là người
này nghỉ thì người kia có rảnh hôm nay
để ốp vào hay không chẳng hạn thế hoặc
là tính công chấm công người dùng sẽ cứ
nhập chấm công vào so với sau sự xuất ra
thống kê là tỷ lệ là năng suất đi làm
hay là gần như
tính ra thì cái đấy nó chênh lệch rõ
ràng là cái nguồn nhập vào với cái hiển
thị ra nó khác rất khác nhau Máy tính sẽ
phải tự động tính hộ cái đấy và con
người tự tính cái đấy sẽ rất là mất thời
gian kiểu gần như thế sẽ khó dùng đều
bằng Excel hay word chứ đoán đoán một
thứ K không cần trang web không cần
trang web của mấy ông người ta dùng bằng
Excel người ta lưu người ta lưu bằng
giấy người ta vẫn làm được bởi vì nó
không có bài toán gì đó cần phải xử lý
bằng máy móc không cần tính toán còn đồ
án 2 thì bắt buộc là những cái kiểu
phải phải can thiệp sâu hơn ví dụ dạng
như là như tôi bây giờ chuẩn bị chữa đó
làm chi à là khách hàng cứ đặt lịch các
thứ thôi nhưng mình vẫn phải đề xuất ra
được là Ok thế thì thế thì Lịch Trống
của ví dụ Giả sử Bây giờ tôi sắp đề cập
là ví dụ là
à vì ví dụ là như là
bây giờ có đặt đặt lịch khám chẳng hạn
đúng không có rất nhiều bác sĩ nhưng mà
khung giờ làm việc à không không Giờ Tuy
là giả sử khung giờ làm việc của bạn mấy
bác sĩ cố định đi đúng không ạ Nhưng mà
lúc mà khách đặt vào vào lúc giờ này thì
kiểm tra lại danh sách là có bác có
những bác sĩ nào đang rảnh giờ này đúng
chứ Đấy khách hàng đặt giờ khác lại phải
đề xuất ra danh sách bác sĩ rảnh đúng
vào giờ đấy đúng không ạ kiểm tra trong
cái lịch mà khách hàng đã đặt thì thay
vì có một nhân viên để ngồi trực trực ở
đấy để mà ngồi kiểm tra
bây giờ có hàng trăm khách hàng vào rồi
một nhân viên hỏi và nhân viên ngồi làm
vỡ mồm đúng chứ Hãy để máy tính tự động
làm được đấy khách máy tính tự đề xuất
nhân viên thực à Làm sao cho mà thực tế
thực tế là nhân viên chỉ cần người chốt
cuối thôi hãy tiện nhất cho nhân viên
không còn được tuyển nhiều nhân viên thì
ngồi trực để mà kiểu kiểm tra xem là
kiểm tra thủ công bằng tay
không thậm chí là phải gọi lại bác sĩ
đấy xác nhận không không phải làm như
thế đúng chứ Hãy để máy tính kiểm tra
hết mấy cái vụ đấy
nghĩa là mình sẽ giảm được bài toán về
con người đúng không ạ Đấy thì bây giờ
tôi sẽ thử làm vụ đấy nhé Tôi sẽ làm cái
cậu rất là đơn giản tôi sẽ
triển lãm là tôi có tạo một
tôi sẽ bao gồm làm cả hai tính năng này
bao gồm lấy ra danh sách trống trước sau
đó thì tôi đặt lịch sau đó thì tôi lại
đặt thêm một lần nữa để kiểm tra xem là
danh sách trống lúc sau hiển thị ra thì
nó có hợp lý hay không Ok không ạ Bây
giờ tôi sẽ tạo đầu tiên thì tôi sẽ tạo
đương nhiên là bây giờ tôi sẽ thử vẽ ra
tao bây giờ theo kiểu databa đơn giản
đâu nhé Đấy nó sẽ là như sau
nhỉ
cài cái tiện ích di sản Viber sẽ dễ nhìn
thôi
Ông mấy ông xem cái tên Scope
Đúng rồi quên quên quên
chạy cái install đã
cho Minecraft
câu truy vấn thôi là một cái thì lấy
thằng cha và một cái lấy thằng con đúng
chứ Đấy còn nếu mà làm đệ quy thì nó
cũng sẽ hình như là nó sẽ chỉ lấy nếu
thế Tôi nghĩ là chỉ lấy hai thôi vẫn lấy
thằng cha xong rồi lấy thằng con của tất
cả những thằng cha đấy rồi nó sẽ nó sẽ
ra rất nhiều mảng xuống nó sẽ marketing
nó sẽ dùng cốt để marketing vụ đấy chứ
nó không Tôi nghĩ là nó không làm phức
tạp và truy vấn có bao nhiêu truy vấn
lấy dần dần con con con con con con con
con con thế thì vỡ mồm đúng không ạ
ở đây tôi sẽ có là gì bây giờ tôi sẽ có
là đầu tiên này
nghĩa bản à Đây
tiếp theo có bảng là bảng
chất là mình mình đặt lịch thì mình sẽ
có bảng bảng booking chẳng hạn
ID này mình sẽ có
thường nó sẽ chia ra khung giờ
kiểu thường là kiểu
lưu Ca ấy kiểu thế ví dụ là kiểu tôi cứ
cho là lưu ca nhé sẽ kiểu ship như này
đi cho dễ nhé tiếp theo nào là Doctor ID
Giả sử thế
Giả sử rất là đơn giản như này thôi Chỉ
Có mỗi như thế này đúng chứ Đấy Ok đầu
tiên thì bây giờ giả sử Tôi có rất nhiều
bác sĩ lúc đầu hiển thị toàn bộ bác sĩ
ấy vì tất cả bác sĩ đến
khi mà đặt theo ca các thứ thì kiểm tra
bác sĩ bận hay không vân vân đương nhiên
còn thêm những cái kiểu nữa là theo ngày
nữa nhưng mà mấy cái tình tiết đấy thì
mấy ông què thêm là được đúng chứ Giờ
tôi chỉ có hai bảng này đơn giản thôi
mấy ông hình dung bài toán không nhỉ
Hình dung mà đúng không
khó hiểu gì Hỏi ngay nhé Không thì tôi
có mặc định cho mấy ông là hiểu hết rồi
cái việc bang livestream như này mấy ông
có lợi duy nhất ở điểm so với những cái
bạn xem sau là mấy ông hỏi được hỏi trực
tiếp được để tôi trả lời luôn còn nếu
mấy ông mà ngồi nghe chỉ nghe thôi Thì
thực ra mấy ông ngồi xem livestream làm
gì chẳng làm gì cho vui
cái lợi nhất là cái mình có thể hỏi được
trực tiếp luôn mà
chứ mấy cái bạn sau rồi Mấy bạn đấy sẽ
bị ngại khi mà kiểu nhắn tin hỏi các thứ
thứ đúng không Mà tôi cũng sẽ lúc đấy
tôi cũng sẽ không biết được mấy bạn ấy
đang hỏi gì trả lời đúng không nên em
mấy ông thực sự nên tận dụng ý tôi tôi
thường hay tận dụng kiểu khi mà học trên
lớp tôi chỉ tận dụng được mỗi đấy Không
thì mình ở nhà học cho nhanh tức là dựng
hỏi thầy liên tục cái gì Hỏi được thì
tranh thủ hỏi luôn
ID tự động tăng này sẽ có table
tưởng thế nào
bây giờ nó đi soi Cũng tương đối đúng
nghĩa bởi vì trong này có Bạn post và
bạn khóa học mà
để số được
không hiểu
đúng không ạ
Bây giờ thì mình làm như thế nào bây giờ
đầu tiên là tôi cứ Insert trước thủ công
một vài Bác sĩ đúng không ạ
thì bây giờ đầu tiên là tôi cần vào cái
trang hiển thị toàn bộ bác sĩ đúng chứ
không tôi sẽ việc lấy bác sĩ nó là nó là
nó là kiểu linh hoạt ra sao tôi chọn Tôi
chọn ca này thì bác sĩ danh sách bác sĩ
rảnh như này nhưng ca khác thì danh sách
bác sĩ nó sẽ thay đổi nên là tôi sẽ
không truyền cố định cái danh sách bác
sĩ vào Lúc đầu Lúc đầu tôi sẽ kiểu hiển
thị ra cái view các thứ thứ bình thường
sau đó thì dùng ra Switch để gọi lên api
Lấy toàn bộ bác sĩ về hiểu không ạ Bây
giờ mình sẽ có là một cái form như này
đúng chứ có một cái form sẽ là chọn K
nha
chọn ca thì mình không nên cho người
dùng Điền sẽ cố định giả
nhỏ hơn bằng sự là có 4k thôi chẳng hạn
qua nó là cô cô pilot nhé hồi trước tôi
từ dùng cái Tab Life nó mất phí nhưng mà
có pilot này tôi thấy ngon hơn nó đọc có
vẻ hiểu hơn mà nó nhẹ hơn thằng táp Life
nó ăn ram phết nên là tôi phải bỏ đi rồi
hiển thị ra ca các thứ thì mình gọi
booking ngay đúng chứ mặc định là Ca Đầu
Tiên Thực ra thích thì ông Nghĩa là ngay
từ vừa vào vừa vào như này ông ấy có
đoạn Ra squip đây tôi sẽ dùng Giga rồi
bằng gì tôi sẽ có một cái Ở đây bây giờ
này chọn bác sĩ Đúng chưa
mình sẽ có select ở đây mình sẽ có ID ở
đây là select Doctor như này
xử lý cái này đầu tiên khi trang 10 load
vào Tôi sẽ gọi Ajax
ở đây sẽ mình sẽ có router gọi đến là
tên là ví dụ ghét
để phô mai thớt là ghét
sừng cho cái data mình sẽ truyền lên hàm
số cái gì
không nên dùng đăng để xem nào của nó và
mình nên chuyển lên tham số gì mình nên
chuyển lên cái sheet cái mà ca mà mình
đã chọn đây tôi sẽ đặt đi cho nó
Selection
rồi tôi sẽ lấy giá trị về là
khi mà chạy xong này
đây giả sử như này tôi sẽ
ra không cần phải lock nó ra đấy còn phê
thì mấy ông tự xử lý nhé Tôi từng dạy mà
ông về cái giặt dùng này rồi nhưng đại
khái thì tôi sẽ có một cái router như
này đúng chứ tôi sẽ
ở đây Tôi có một cái router này
ai như này thì bây giờ mình sẽ cần là gì
mình sẽ cần Return trả về hết toàn bộ
danh sách Doctor đang trống đúng không ạ
Và mình đầu tiên mình phải truyền lên
cái gì mình sẽ chuyển lên
cái ca mình sẽ lấy ship này
tài khoản request gate
Sau đó mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ toàn bộ bác
sĩ không
đấy thì tôi sẽ gọi đến
Bình tĩnh bình tĩnh gọi Doctor đã nha
Tôi sẽ có reasonship này
lịch đúng chứ
Thì mình sẽ có là logic function này là
booking này
và mình sẽ returned
sẽ booking class
thế xong rồi đấy
những bác sĩ nào
à
que has à
Mẹ Đã dần hát đây nghĩa là những bác sĩ
nào không có cà chồng trong buổi hôm đấy
là xong như này và lấy ra được các bác
sĩ dành hết Xong
bây giờ mình sẽ ăn thôi
những cái tôi từng Thực ra là mấy bạn để
ý là tôi từng đăng lên blog của tôi rồi
này là có cả về
tôi sẽ cập nhật trên cái này sau và tiếp
theo là Subscribe text của tôi đã cài
cái gì này
ngày và thôi mà
thêm ngày ở đây cao cả ngày ở đây thôi
mà
Tôi sẽ thử mở cái cửa sổ inps lên để mấy
ông tiện theo dõi nhé Network này chọn
vào bên xr nhé Tại trang này lập tức là
nó sẽ gọi gọi lên để lấy về toàn bộ các
bác sĩ đang rảnh tôi sẽ thử mở tele
Scope mấy ông tiện theo dõi hơn nhé này
vấn Tức là sao lấy câu như này nó lấy
lấy tất cả các bác sĩ không nằm trong
cái việc là
ấn ở đây xem kỹ hơn này đây không nằm
trong việc kiểu
Uầy bây giờ nó sửa lại Facebook nhìn
trông giao diện đẹp hơn hẳn nhìn dễ đọc
hơn hồi trước là kiểu cái này thẳng hết
một dòng
không Đương nhiên bây giờ booking không
có gì cả đương nhiên nó sẽ Thì bây giờ
mình việc đơn giản mình chỉ đổ dữ liệu
vào trong này thì thôi thì mình sẽ là
đây
nó sẽ là như này tôi sẽ tạo ra một cái
biến là led
đấy
quá chuẩn rồi
gợi ý này quá Đúng rồi Nhưng mà cốt này
cốt vẫn còn nông dân thực ra không nên
không nên nối chuỗi kiểu không không
thực sự không nên nói chuỗi kiểu ở
option kiểu như này mà nên kiểu dùng cái
hàm có sẵn của nó để mà tạo
Subaru nhưng đôi khi thì không trong
trường hợp này ông đang thấy nó sắp free
nhưng đôi khi nó tách hẳn hai câu truy
vấn nó tùy ứng biến theo là kiểu em em
bởi vì hat many đôi khi nó là kiểu dạng
là là sẽ sắp ra nhưng mà giả One hay cái
gì đó Vừa nãy em thấy là vừa nãy ngay
vừa nãy đây thôi
động ứng biến thế nên là Nhưng mà thực
tế thực tế thì sắp có đi nó luôn nặng
hơn so với roi nên là nhiều lúc nhiều
lúc thì để mà tối ưu thì nên dùng cho
thì tôi đang nói dở cái đoạn này Thực ra
cái Đoạn này đoạn code nó khá nông dân
kiểu là ina cả ông phải ghi thẳng như
này Thực ra có rất nhiều hàm của thằng
Siri để mà ông sẽ tạo cái này ra bằng
thẻ HTML
thích cái việc là là nối theo kiểu như
này ít nhất là như thế này tôi sẽ thích
nối theo kiểu Từng dòng tất cả sao Rồi
sao tôi sẽ có thể kết kiểu này nhé Tôi
sẽ nối Cậu này mấy ông xem nó có trông
nó có vẻ ổn hơn không nhé
sẽ mường tượng được là đoạn nào đoạn thể
mở đoạn nào đoạn giữa và đoạn nào thể
đóng ít nhất là như thế này còn nếu mà
ông dùng được cả hàm các thứ thử nữa thì
càng ngon nhiều tôi không Tôi không
hướng dẫn Hàn nữa vì cơ bản thì về chả
ai dùng gì cả
nhưng mà ít ra Kiểu này thì trông nó
phải tường minh hơn tường minh hơn phần
nào và với ông gì về sau ông dễ sửa cái
thằng ở giữa hơn còn đâu về cơ bản thì
không thay đổi rồi đấy Tuấn Long như này
đúng chứ đúng chứ
ca nào sẽ thế thôi
à Đúng rồi Bây giờ Bây giờ thì tôi sẽ
tống cái này tổng cái này nha
tôi tạo một cái hàm răng Trần này xong
rồi Ghét free Doctor đúng chứ
mặc định là lúc đầu vào tôi gọi hàm này
nhưng mà bất kỳ khi nào mà cái thằng này
nó thay đổi thì lại gọi hàm hàm này phát
nữa đấy
khi K thay đổi thì mình sẽ phải cậu
đúng không gọi K2 lại lấy lại danh sách
đúng chứ rất xịn đấy Bây giờ Bây giờ tôi
sẽ thử đặt Tôi đặt lịch nhé Đặt lịch thì
tôi sẽ tôi đặt lịch này mình sẽ có một
cái nút bắt Tân ở đây đi
ok anh ạ
à Tôi có nền đây nữa nêm sẽ là ship đúng
chứ và nêm ở đây sẽ là Apple ID
nhảy đến cái
Action sẽ nhảy lên cái router là thường
là sẽ là
buồn cười điểm mà booking nó vừa động từ
nó vừa là nó vừa là ở
danh từ đặt tên để store vậy
nghe đi giả sử như này đi
lại trang này Tôi đặt lịch bác sĩ 1 với
mọi thứ đều 1 đúng không
sẽ kiểu như này
ở trên này cho dù biến này ông chỉ dùng
một lần ở dưới Nhưng mà như tôi đã từng
nói là toàn bộ khai báo trên như này vào
cái xử lý này đôi khi mình sẽ tách ra
mua đồ hoặc là chỉ đơn giản là nhìn này
dễ tưởng mình là hiểu à là trong cái hàm
này mình có lấy những cái request gì về
sau mình sẽ sửa ở chỗ đấy thôi sửa chỗ
đấy chứ không phải là kéo xuống dưới tôi
Tôi thấy rất nhiều người là kiểu thấy nó
biến thành dùng ở một chỗ thôi Nên là
gọi hẳn dưới Giả sử giả sử như này nhé
Chỉ có nhiều ông lười kiểu như là
cứ bắt người sau phải đoán Tao tao sử
dụng biến nào truyền lên các thứ Nhìn
trông có vẻ không trượt lên cái gì cả
đúng không ạ Đấy Xong rồi ông kia Không
biết từ đấy khiến nó vài Dead các thứ
thử sai chẳng hạn thế
nên là không Không nên như thế vẫn làm
theo kiểu như này
đôi khi mấy ông cốt là mình không phải
nghĩ việc người sau nữa chứ không phải
là cốt xong luôn được xịn quá đúng không
ạ Đấy mình sẽ có booking như này mình sẽ
ra không cần
xong kiểu như này đương nhiên là mình sẽ
phải có
phi able
kiểu
publicem bằng fail nữa Ok
tại trang này
có vẻ in search được rồi
nếu mà inser được rồi Như này khi mà
quay lại cả trong booking
như này thì các bạn thấy không hề còn
bạn Long nữa đúng không ạ Nhưng mà nếu
sang ca thứ hai thì bạn Long lại xuất
hiện ok chưa Đúng rồi
thể sinh viên tôi vẫn phải trả phí
ok thì câu truy vấn các thứ các bạn cũng
sẽ thấy ở đây nó lấy xong rồi lưu lại
như thế nào xử lý như thế nào
để bản chất là không phải Isaac theo
kiểu
Nó là kiểu là gọi gọi dùng ra Switch
phải gọi lên để lấy dữ liệu về đấy thì
không phải Ajax thì cũng là một cái cậu
khác để mà nó
động như thế này còn nếu mà em không
muốn làm ra skip thì em muốn làm pp
thuần ý thì em sẽ phải cưỡng một lần
chọn K xong rồi phải ấn nút để mà load
lại cái bác sĩ này thì không ai làm thế
Cả
đúng rồi bản chất nó là xh nhưng mà nó
là kiểu dạng là hàm khác của bên mấy cái
thư viện kiểu facebook các thứ thôi nó
không bản chất nó như nhau nó vẫn là ra
squip là một hai nó vẫn là đều xhr tất
cả là gọi dữ liệu lên các thứ
ví dụ bốc bát sỹ Đúng rồi Đúng rồi book
theo giờ nó sẽ khó hơn nó sẽ kiểu a các
thứ nữa
theo giờ đúng không Thì bạn nhưng mà ý ý
ở đây mình chữa mình không phải chữa
theo cậu theo theo kiểu là là để mà chữa
hẳn dứt điểm bài toán các bạn cái này
các bạn cũng nên tự chủ động để mà suy
nghĩ các thứ giải quyết cái việc theo
giờ ý thì về cơ bản về cơ bản ấy nó là
các bạn sẽ phải cái câu truy vấn các bạn
select nó sẽ phải lằng nhằng hơn ở cái
đoạn kiểm tra xem là bác sĩ Rảnh hay
không thôi nhưng nhưng về cái mặt nghiệp
vụ thì nó vẫn giống nhau đó là lấy ra
được bác sĩ rảnh bằng cách là kiểm tra
xem là có lịch trống hay có lịch tại
thời điểm đấy Không đúng chứ nghĩa là
mình đang sửa các bạn là để các bạn hình
dung ra bài toán nghiệp vụ chứ mình
không chữa theo cậu dạng là cho ăn sẵn
thì các bạn đúng nghĩa là các bạn cop
hết phúc của mình về là xong được cái đồ
án rồi thì hết thứ để mà làm mất rồi
đúng không ạ
Tại bây giờ mình nghĩ là cái bài toán
nghiệp vụ này có nhiều bạn vẫn còn đang
thắc mắc thì mình sẽ chữa theo mức độ
đơn giản và và
tối giản nhất để mà các bạn nhìn vào các
bạn hình dung được thôi Chứ các bạn
không thể mà Có code này về để biến
thành cái đồ án các bạn được đúng chứ
còn ông bố tôi chữa thêm cụ thể hơn nữa
thì khác gì tôi làm hết hộ đồ ăn của ông
mất rồi
các bạn hiểu không ạ
Nói chung là đồ án này thì
tôi vẫn là người hướng dẫn đúng không ạ
Và tôi sẽ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn ở một
cái mức tương đối thôi tôi khẳng định ở
việc mà tôi chữa đến như bây giờ rồi ấy
khẳng định như bây giờ rồi ấy thì thì
thì nó nó như là chữa Chắc phải 60 đến
70% rồi đúng không ạ gần như là 40 30%
hẹn gặp lại các bạn sẽ phải hình dung
bài toán và các bạn sẽ phải tự code nữa
các thứ thứ nữa
giờ là chuẩn thì nó không khác gì cả
đừng để cho khách hàng chọn giờ à Đúng
rồi Nhân tiện thể tôi quên mất đấy hôm
hôm qua hôm qua tôi đi tôi đi
cắt tóc
ở một cái quán sang chảnh cực Chắc là
bây giờ tôi cũng phải quay mấy ông bởi
vì ở cái cái cái tôi thích nhất cái cái
đặt lịch của nó mỗi tội là lúc mà đến
cái bước cuối Ấn đặt không được buồn
cười Nhưng mà cái trang này Công nhận
xịn để đặt lịch
loại cát đặt xong rồi cái này cái này
vẫn chọn được nhưng nó sẽ kiểu tô màu
xám rồi Kiểu không không khuya không
khuyên dùng
Tại sao lại bấm vào hiển thị ra lý do
đấy
như thế này
sau giả sử chọn cái này này đề xuất lại
không khuyên dùng các thứ nhưng có thể
bấm được Có thể bấm được nhé
Giả sử thậm chí là bỏ qua cái này tao
không cạo râu chẳng hạn
rồi có thể nó sẽ kiểu Cái này gọi ốc sên
tất cả nó có thể thêm những cái đi kèm
nữa nếu các bạn chọn đấy không muốn thêm
này
xong rồi Cái này buồn cười vãi
bạn bạn hãy chọn thợ của bạn một là kiểu
Junior Nhưng mà cái này Junior nó nó
ngồi khoe luôn là của bọn tao không có
video bọn tao Biến hết thành simio xong
bắt buộc phải chọn này tăng lên 100.000
hiển thị không giờ nó hiển thị ra toàn
bộ giờ cho các bạn chọn xong rồi nó sẽ
tự động cộng thêm cái số thời gian mà
mình đã chọn những cái dịch vụ là sửa
đây nó có đề cấp dịch vụ ở đây một tiếng
này 45 phút này hay cái gì gì đó như này
này
cộng thêm cộng thêm cộng thêm để nó sẽ
hiển thị ra thôi thì kiểu thế mấy ông
hình dung không
cái gì hay mình sẽ học đúng không ạ Cái
gì Dở của nó thì mình sẽ né Chắc chắn
rồi thì các bạn sẽ cài càng học hỏi thêm
được nhiều đúng không ạ Tôi bây giờ ví
dụ bây giờ tôi dùng kể cả Facebook hay
dùng bất kỳ gì tôi sẽ thấy tôi bắt đầu
ngồi So sánh Tại sao thằng Facebook so
với thằng Twitter chẳng hạn nó khác nhau
những cái điểm gì chẳng hạn thế nó hướng
đến cái điểm gì mấy ông có ở thắc mắc
điều đấy ví dụ điển hình á Ông mấy ông
có biết được thằng thích Twitter nó đăng
bài nó có giới hạn ký tự không
chẳng hạn thế cũng đã là giống như là
Tại sao Tik Tok nó nổi hơn nó cùng là
mạng nền tảng về video nó lại nó nó tự
nhiên lại vượt nổi lên trong khi đó là
có rất nhiều nền tảng về video rồi cái
chẳng hạn nổi lên vì sao đấy Chẳng hạn
mình sẽ thắc mắc những cái đấy nó hướng
lên đối tượng là gì đấy nhu cầu của
người dùng thực sự là gì Vân và để hướng
đến đối tượng đấy thì nó sẽ làm những
cái gì để càng ngày đối tượng đấy sẽ
càng cần nó hơn đúng không ạ sẽ phát
triển lên như thế nào vân vân đấy là cái
suy nghĩ của dân công nghệ của mình đúng
không ạ người dùng bình thường có nghĩ
cái điều đấy không ít đúng không Nhưng
mà chắc chắn mình sẽ phải học hỏi mình
phải nghĩ những điều đấy thì mình mới
làm cái sản phẩm mình lên được đúng
không ạ Tôi đang vẫn đang hướng đến mấy
ông là suy nghĩ như một lập trình viên
thực sự là một đi vlogper Tức là nhà
phát triển nghĩa là nhìn vào những cái
người khác đã làm để phát triển để nâng
cấp nó lên để để không phải để sao chép
nữa mà để nâng cấp mình sẽ học hỏi những
người trước để nâng cấp lên chứ không
phải là một cốt đơ một Cốt Đơn là chỉ
ngồi gõ lại những cái gì mà mình đã biết
và chỉ gõ lại những cái gì mình đã được
dạy tôi không hướng mấy ông như thế đúng
không ạ Thường mấy ông kiểu phát triển
phát triển lên các thứ
thầy có chữa code không ạ là ok bây giờ
xong xong xong mấy cái các bạn thắc mắc
rồi đấy bây giờ Nhóm nào cần mình chữa
nhỉ
gọi thôi gọi Mít nhé để mình sẽ chữa
luôn
trước
Ý bạn là ngôn ngữ lập trình nào trước á
Ở
học đi học lập trình rồi chứ kia cậu ông
xác định ông không học theo đại học
nhưng mà tôi vẫn không hưởng mấy ông như
thế
[âm nhạc]
nhưng mà thích thì vẫn phải học mấy cái
cơ bản cũng được tí hon trước cũng được
ra bạn ra vào lúc đầu khó lắm Chào em
nhóm em nhóm mấy nhỉ
không
bán vé
nhớ là hôm trước là anh nhớ nhìn trông
nó cứ bị loạn đấy đúng không
đúng không Bởi vì nhiều cái loạn quá
[âm nhạc]
luôn không còn bằng
không
lấy thêm cái propin name
cái thằng này trước khi em lấy để tránh
việc nó sẽ bị n cái truy vấn em sẽ phải
quit thêm ở đây
rồi
mặc định đâu
đừng có nên mặc định để pâu có gì cả
Mình vẫn ghi thêm ở đây thôi
đây là của thằng sation
Còn đây là em đang gọi nó là đô lazip
thẳng như này luôn Chứ em đâu gọi thông
qua cái thằng này em đâu có gọi thông
qua thằng season đâu
Đúng chứ
em đã gọi đây là gọi từ thằng em muốn
gọi theo kiểu như này thì em sẽ phải gọi
thông qua thằng season nó như này cơ
như thế này đấy
[âm nhạc]
nhất thì em phải cài DD box 3 hoặc là
tele Scope
đây em sẽ hiểu để mà em sửa cái có truy
vấn đương nhiên là cái này toàn bộ là
mới với các bạn thì thực ra là anh không
đòi hỏi khắt khe gì lắm nhưng mà ý anh à
đoạn này anh chỉ cho mấy em để em biết
cách để tối ưu mà đúng không để mà mình
mới cho dễ sửa các thứ
như thế này
nhưng mà thôi kệ vậy
[âm nhạc]
tốt tổ đây
cái đoạn này hồi hôm trước anh hơi khó
hiểu này cái đoạn này xử lý như nào nhỉ
cái đoạn này anh chưa hiểu cái logic
đoạn này lắm
em em lưu trong database là lưu số phút
thôi ạ Thì hôm trước anh có nói đấy thì
mình lưu lại nó là số phút
thúc chưa nhỉ
thấy chưa
1440 mà tức là nằm trong vòng 1 ngày ạ
Còn cái Drive này là là nó sẽ cộng thêm
những cái ngày ở phía sau thì mình chỉ
cần chia dư chưa lấy phần mềm
ngày
hành
đúng không Và Cùng lắm là
giờ cái giờ giờ mà kiểu nó gọn nhẹ
cái thời gian mà nó di chuyển là tốn mất
bao nhiêu thì lúc đấy em phải quy hạnh
phúc sau em sẽ dùng hàng để cộng vào để
mà về sau em có thể dùng bằng chính câu
SQL hay truy vấn được là là cái cái xe
đấy nó đang di chuyển hay không em Làm
kiểu này thì em truy vấn kiểu gì
tại thời điểm hiện tại sẽ xe có đang
đang đi hay không
ông ông lấy cái đấy ra kiểu gì bây giờ
Anh hiểu ý em nhớ rằng đang nói là khi
mà em làm cậu Lưu kiểu như này em sẽ rất
khó để truy vấn những cái khác
bởi vì em lưu lưu lại cái không phải lưu
lại thời gian Mỗi lần em lưu này là con
số thì em lại phải tính toán lại để mà
em ra được thời gian thì em sẽ không tận
dụng được những cái hàm thời gian
em làm sao biết được là là
trong thời gian này là có những xe đang
chạy xe nào sắp chạy em sẽ làm kiểu gì
em lại phải lấy thời gian rồi em mới
tính à không phải làm thế Cả
Nói chung là có hàm thời gian lý do cả
bây giờ đoạn này em phải sửa đã bay đấy
anh có việc cái database kiểu như kiểu
số food đâu nhỉ
thời gian mình phải lưu lại thời gian để
mình xử lý chứ mình không lưu lại là số
phút hai cái gì đó Đương nhiên nó bị
thừa với cái khoản dây này gì đó nhưng
cái đấy kệ không sao cả thực ra chuẩn
nhất là mình lưu lại dạng thực ra lý
tưởng nhất đấy vẫn luôn lưu lại ở dạng
time để về sau mình có thể quy đổi cái
thời gian đấy ra mọi cái khác theo ngày
giờ hay là dùng phút gì đó hay là thậm
chí là mình xử lý vài cái thời gian đấy
mình đỡ phải dùng cái hàm để mà convert
nó ra thăm xem thì mình mới format được
lý tưởng nhất vẫn luôn là lưu lại dạng
Hamster em ạ Đấy bỏ bỏ mấy cái phút phần
phút sai rồi
nhưng mà
một cái cốp của nó thì tốt em tạo một
cái cốp đi anh thấy vẫn chưa dùng cái
code gì cả
info hay cái gì đó tùy em đặt xong rồi
chuyển dạ là gọi gọi như này thôi
2 định ẩn đi toàn bộ những cái mình
không cần chẳng hạn thế
không thì em thử code thử xem
Tống nó ra một cái hàm số đặt tên là cái
hàm đấy thì sẽ hình dung được đoạn này
cốt
cái gì
thực ra không nên chuyển không biên biến
nó thành alloween nó lợi hơn adray rất
nhiều Nếu em muốn dùng kiểu mát kiểu như
này đi ăn nữa thì về cơ bản nó dùng hàm
mát nó vẫn xịn hơn rất nhiều
ki thì em sẽ gọi theo kiểu dạng khác
thôi em sẽ gọi kiểu dạng như này thì nó
là kia thôi
không khác gì cả
đọc anh không hiểu cốt rồi
ông lưu là phút như thế thì đuổi xuống
đấy
cơ bản nó vẫn là nền móng về sau Hiện
tại em vẫn có thể code được nhưng về sau
nó sẽ rất khó nâng cấp và và bảo trì về
sau thêm tính năng nó sẽ rất khó hoặc là
về sau muốn xử lý thêm một cái vấn đề
liên quan đến thời gian cũng không làm
được
không ai làm kiểu đấy cả nếu giờ em lưu
là thời gian là ngày thì em phải đến
ngày sau trường ngày trước đã biết được
thời gian nó đi là bao lâu
không thực ra như anh đã bảo ấy thì em
Em có thể lưu lại là thời gian bắt đầu
và thời gian thời gian đi thôi rồi Từ
đấy mình sẽ quy ước được là thời gian
kết thúc là là lúc nào
thường là như thế chứ
như thế thì làm sao mà xác định được
đúng không
Đúng rồi Nghĩa là nghĩa là ví dụ là giả
sử là đi bắt đầu từ 7 giờ tối nay đúng
không Nhưng mà thôi thời gian chuyến đi
ở tận 6 tiếng thì mình sẽ tự động biết
được là sẽ sang ngày hôm sau chẳng hạn
thế
đúng không
tiên em đi lại thời gian khởi hành thôi
mà đúng không sau đó thì em
sau đó thì khách hàng đặt vào ngày nào
thì em cộng thêm thời gian đấy để ra
được là là kiểu kết thúc là tại ngày nào
giờ nào Chú không thấy đặt vé bình
thường đặt vé xe buýt hay đặt máy bay
cũng thế à sẽ luôn cộng thêm 2 tiếng
cộng thêm 3 Tài Chính nó sẽ đề xuất ra
cái chẳng ai làm nữa cố định thời gian
kết thúc như thế cả em vẫn sẽ luôn là
thời gian bắt đầu
cộng thêm thời gian quãng quá trình thì
sẽ ra được thời gian kết thúc nó không
lưu lại thời gian kết thúc
gian đầu và thêm kết thúc luôn mình chỉ
đúng rồi anh hiểu ý em nhưng mà Đấy là
do là em cố định cái thời gian bắt đầu
và em cố định thời gian thời gian quá
trình nên nó sẽ ra nó sẽ hiển thị ra đấy
ra kết thúc chứ không phải mình lưu lại
thời gian kết thúc phân biệt nha phân
biệt nha Mình không lưu lại thời gian
kết thúc bởi vì về sau em có thể thay
đổi thời gian quá trình thì thời gian
kết thúc em lại phải thay đổi à đúng
không
phút thì nó cũng vậy thôi
Cái gì ông ý kiếm cái gì ông đi gọi tham
xem cơ mà chứ không phải ngày
[âm nhạc]
liên quan đến ông Nếu thế Lưu lại kiểu
than thôi em lưu lại kiểu tham thôi Nó
có giờ phút thôi
là lưu lại tham nhé Xong rồi thời gian
quãng đường đi thế thôi em sẽ lưu lại
mỗi hai cái đấy
Vào thời gian quãng đường đi em sẽ lưu
lại ở phút sau em sẽ cộng số phút đấy em
dùng hàm của sq cũng được Em dùng cộng
số phút đấy cộng với thời gian
cộng với thời gian bắt đầu thì em sẽ ra
được thời gian kết thúc là lúc nào thế
xong
đưa ID nó sẽ là cái gì nhỉ
một nhà cung cấp xe nhà xe
bụng quá
em sau nhé